[Music]
welcome to the future of Robotics let
them help you chores around the house
there isn't anything they can't
[Music]
do the next marvelous advancement in
robotics is artificial intelligence by
studying the human brain we have given
independent thought and Life to robots
allowing them to join the American
Workforce almost like real
people now a new technology is Bridging
the Gap between humans and AI making us
closer than ever by scanning your own
facial features we can give them to a
fully robotic body making them more
human than human with a simulant the
Futures never looked
[Music]
better AI is integrated into all parts
of our day-to-day life they cook our
meals they Drive our cars they are our
civil servants keeping the peace and
with the new state-of-the-art defense
system they
[Music]
even